let me ask you about climate change
there's a let's go from the meme to the
to the profound philosophy okay the meme
was there's a clip of you talking about
climate change and saying that the
Aquaman meme uh you said that for the
sake of argument if the water level
arises five to ten feet in the next
hundred years people will just sell
their homes and move
and then the meme is sell to who uh can
you argue both sides of that the
argument that they're making is a straw
man the argument that I'm making is over
time I don't mean that if a tsunami is
about to hit your house you can list it
on eBay that's not that's not what I
mean obviously what I mean is that human
beings have an extraordinary ability to
adapt it's actually our best quality and
that as water levels rise real estate
prices in those areas tends to fall that
over time people tend to abandon those
areas they tend to leave they tend to
right now sell their houses and then
they tend to move and eventually those
houses will be worthless and you won't
have anybody to sell to but presumably
not that many people will be living
there by that point which is one of the
reasons why the price would be low
because there's no demand so it's over a
hundred years so all of these price
Dynamics are very gradual relative to
the other price Dynamics correct that's
why the joke of it of course is that
like I'm saying that tomorrow there's a
tsunami on your Source step and you're
like oh Bob will buy my house Bob ain't
gonna buy your house like we all get
that but it's a funny meme I laughed at
it